welcome to the man of Recaps this is The
Walking Dead season 11 episode 18. and
if you're a Walking Dead fan it's time
to get some awesome official merch from
The Walking Dead shop I've got one of
their supply drop boxes right here stay
tuned after the recap we'll see what's
inside last episode ended with the
quadruple trap standoff but now it's
interrupted by Mercer and Pamela Milton
showing up in person yeah Carol brought
him here like it's all right we worked
out a deal she wants Lance horns be
alive to take the fall for her son
Sebastian's actions but Daryl was ready
for some Revenge stabs his hand like
yeah he'll live and so Lance Hornsby is
under arrest Pamela Milton blames
everything on him getting her son
Sebastian out of trouble and she does a
good job selling it the people of the
Commonwealth who were rioting last
episode are now like hey thanks Governor
now after this negative experience with
the Commonwealth most of our crew is
like yeah we're just going home but over
the course of the episode they all have
combos like hey actually the
Commonwealth is mostly good should we
stay and try to make it better but it's
little Judith Grimes is talking with her
uncle Daryl like hey running away now is
being coward we should stay and help
make it a better place but it's Eugene's
lady love Max Pamela Milton's assistant
who is now committed to exposing her
corruption in fact they go to make a
deal with the devil Lance Hornsby it's
like hey man you knew everything are
there any dirty secrets of Pamela and
Sebastian Milton we can expose get her
taken down and you out of jail maybe but
Lance Hornsby does not seem concerns to
be locked up right now he's like hey if
you're going after the Miltons good luck
but I'm not helping because he's got his
own plans going with his secret agents
that are still loyal to him and I'll
shoot up some civilians but more on that
in a minute because right now it's
Founders Day the biggest Commonwealth
holiday and Pamela Milton wants
Sebastian to give a speech assuring
everyone that he's a good guy but he's
not a good guy he's just an irredeemable
douche and he's just like I don't want
to give this dumb speech but this gives
Max an idea she's got the tape recorder
hits it to record and it's like hey
Sebastian tell me what you really think
so he goes on a little rant the gist of
which is the people of the Commonwealth
are dumb I'll just tell them what they
want to hear so they can keep being poor
and I can keep being rich and some so is
the Founders Day celebration gets
underway with some classic pro wrestling
it's time for Sebastian's speech where
he does a rehearsed pretending to be
unrehearsed throw the script away and
say hey everyone I'm sorry I'm gonna
earn your trust but Max isn't letting
him get away with that because the sound
guy for the event is her boyfriend
Eugene who put in the tape and now it's
playing for the whole Commonwealth to
hear what Sebastian really thinks of
them uh they are not happy it turns into
a bit of a riot which covers the fact
that some zombies show up yeah the
people Lance hornsby's agent shot have
turned now they're wrecking havoc on the
Crowd Oh man Lance horns be some sort of
evil mastermind so it's mass chaos
people running everywhere zombies eating
extras our crew trying to stop him but
Sebastian Milton is making a beeline for
Max he is real mad at her he finally
catches her and there's a walker nearby
so he pushes her into it oh no Max but
there's Eugene nearby coming in with the
tackle oh knocks the zombie into
Sebastian he's holding it off like
somebody help me but the crowd around
him is like you're on your own and so
Sebastian Milton one of the most likable
characters ever gets himself bit after
that play him someone finally takes this
zombie out and it is little Judith
Grimes yeah with the sheriff hat and her
dad Rick's old pistol and that's where
episode 18 comes to an end now check
this out I've just received my new
supply drop subscription box from The
Walking Dead shop join me next week for
the full unboxing of all the fun stuff
inside but right now I get to share one
of the cool things we've got Mercer the
coolest character from the new season
yes it's a bobble head oh look at this
guy The Walking Dead shop is adding cool
new designs for each of these last
episodes so you can grab a souvenir and
celebrate the end of The Walking Dead
this new supply drop is shipping now so
go to The Walking Dead Shop link in the
description and pick up yours
if you liked this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
Recaps of TV and movies
[Music]